when you were doing Law and Order
Criminal Intent now the first time I saw
that I had never seen Law and Order and
I was on the TV and I stopped because I
like you and I started watching you and
I
go what what is he doing what I found
myself I don't know what happened so
captivated in the way you were
delivering and the way you were
just your manners it was like it was
like you were putting it together like a
real person but so quirky and like you
know like you would do these things
where you're like and the the left hand
I'm just trying you were like I could
see you thinking the character thinking
like it was real and and I go did they
like what you were doing right away in
the dailies in the beginning and you
were like no can you elaborate on
that well no they didn't like it at all
I mean they worried about it yeah I
there was I don't know which story I
told you but you know I I would save
certain spots to pause in and not speak
and that that drove them crazy because
you know but I you know I was like this
is not radio like you can stop talking
like it's okay to stop talking and by
the way you could cut it out if you want
you know but um there was
a it was until Dick Wolf got it like he
got it that that um people were
into that weirdness that the idea that I
had the guts enough to just pause and
not speak for a moment um while the the
room is full of actors and the camera is
rolling um he he thought that that was
exciting and and he he they he he was
the one that gave me permission to do
all of that stuff that I was trying to
do and um because I used to block um
those Arya scenes were saved for me to
block like I would block them and I I
never changed the word once the script
was P I gave some notes but very rarely
we had great writers on that show you
know like great writers yeah and um but
uh you know for that kind of thing
they're they're brilliant you know they
were brilliant and
um but but I I wouldn't change the word
but I would block the scene I would
block the scene myself like because I
had it all in my mind of how exactly the
whole thing unfolds and some of those P
some of those SC were 12 to 15 pages
long you know and so of just straight
dogging we used to do them top to bottom
like like a piece of deer like we
wouldn't stop and then do lines like we
would do it top to bottom so if you were
so that sometimes there'd be like three
sometimes there'd be five people in
those scenes coming in and out of the
room and stuff like that it was
fantastic was a Fant and Kate Herby who
plays my partner was from Stephen wolf I
mean she was so ready to to give me
lessons in that kind of work you know
like amazing
so so yeah that that it made them
nervous at first but you know once they
once the companies like that start
making money their nerves go away